so we are now ready to officially and
very safely move on beyond the if Trump
did it phase of the impeachment inquiry
hearings I'm unsure if we are going to
have more public hearings or what the
next step will be we've got the
Thanksgiving holiday coming up hopefully
in the next day or two we will know sort
of the plan trajectory of this entire
thing but particularly with the
testimony on Wednesday by EU Ambassador
Gordon Sunland as we've discussed Trump
did it and everyone knew it Rudy
Giuliani knew what was going on Mike
Pompeo knew what was going on the
National Security Council knew it seems
john bolton may have known it was just
very clear this was annexed or ative
briber as' situation where ukraine could
get military aid could get a meeting
with President Trump if they deliver
politically motivated smear
investigations of Joe and hunter Biden
if they are announced in public press
conferences specifically to help Donald
Trump win re-election in 2020 it
happened we can stop debating that the
real question now is will Trump get away
with it there's a really good piece in
the Detroit metro Times about exactly
this by Jeffrey Billman if the question
is will Trump be impeached and convicted
by the Senate the answer is probably not
we know the data we know that 62 percent
of Trumpets no matter what Trump does
did or could do will never turn on the
guy if they don't turn on Trump
Republicans in the Senate won't turn on
Trump if the question is will Trump be
criminally prosecuted for anything that
he has done the answer is unfortunately
also probably not or it is at least
beyond anything we can strategize around
right now so that very quickly makes the
question of whether Trump will get away
with it one that we can mostly answer in
the sense that Trump getting away with
it would be Trump getting reelected we
can decide whether we vote for him or we
vote him out in less than a year we are
now you know 345 350 days away from the
November of 2020 election we knew from
day one that Donald Trump was corrupt we
suspect
that Republicans would by-and-large fall
in line and let him do whatever the hell
he wants this is the latest test and so
far Republicans are failing the test
very very big time so it now is up to us
quite simply we might have
underestimated or overestimated the
point is we might have assumed that if a
president behaved in this way even
Republicans would say you know it can't
happen that's it no more we were very
wrong if we thought that add to this
that there has always been one justice
and accountability system for the rich
and the powerful and another justice
system for everybody else that just adds
to the political nature of all of this
so I actually think that if there's more
hearings if there's more evidence
presented good we will air it we will
discuss it we will integrate it into our
broader understanding of what it is that
took place but we don't need to keep
arguing about whether Donald Trump did
it they all did it it's very clear now
the issue now is figuring out will there
be repercussions will the right to the
extent that it is participating in the
spin machine crisis-management as it is
the fact they'll become will they
succeed in pushing narratives like
listen Trump called sumblind and said I
don't want to quid pro quo when we
should be wondering as I said yesterday
why is that anything someone would have
to say on the phone if there is not the
belief that maybe there is a quid pro
quo and of course we learned that the
reason Trump did that was because of the
reports that started coming out that day
suggesting that actually there was a
quid pro quo Trump getting on the phone
and saying I don't want to quid pro quo
okay
it's like saying it's like calling up
someone and saying listen I don't want
anything to happen to that lovely little
girl of yours okay
I want her to be safe I don't want
anything to happen to her you understand
what I mean well unless you might have a
role in her not being safe why is this a
phone call that we're having you have to
interpret Trump's behavior more as a
low-grade mob boss who has the desire
but not so much the intellectual
capacity
to carry out a lot of this stuff one of
today's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below